spray sugar with a towel
i guess put the rest in here you feel
good about that
[Laughter]
i don't know how i feel about it hey
guys it's katie and today is going to be
really really fun i have jasmine coming
down to the studio and she thinks she's
going to be making like just a super fun
dessert recipe what she doesn't know is
that i've taken the recipe i've put it
through google translate i went from
english to chinese to gaelic to romanian
to greek and all the way back to english
and we have got a hilariously translated
recipe so i'm excited to see what
jasmine does and it's going to be crazy
jasmine this is what we're going to be
making today okay strawberry king king
let me know if you have any questions
i've never heard this before well that's
because jasmine this recipe's actually
been put through google translate a
bunch of times
can you tell me what it is i can tell
i'll tell you it's a dessert okay so
it's sweet strawberry king king okay
let's do this i guess
it's gonna be great
step one the oven temperature is 350
degrees fahrenheit telling me that it is
but it's not yet so i guess i will go
preheat the oven okay
bake
braided
the oven's preheating let's go to the
next step grease and form a round pie
nine inches and a rectangular pie 10 by
15 inches of skin
what does that mean i have to try and
figure it out yeah
grease and form
a round pie of skin of skin oh parchment
paper
maybe yeah
i'm impressed
scissors this is my least favorite part
about making
strawberry king cakes i learned this
from kelly our culinary producer so i'm
just gonna line this up with the center
and i'm gonna
okay it's not perfect but i think it'll
work i'll just grease more more grease
more better
i'm gonna grease this too
so in sac six eggs a sack i assume would
be a bowl i hope that's correct six eggs
one two
three
four five six one cup of sugar and two
teaspoons of vanilla extract okay it
doesn't even say to mix it just leave it
until it's colorless and tender but i
assume i have to mix it so i will whisk
it
until colorless and tender
oh
colorless and tender is light and fluffy
i understand now
well
now i'm using the electric mixer and i'm
gonna whisk it until it's light and
fluffy this should take like three
minutes ish this is like my least
favorite part about baking using this
because it's just so heavy i didn't sign
up to exercise
okay i think that's good let's move on
to the next step separate one cup of
flour two teaspoons of baking powder one
teaspoon of salt i think separate means
sift based on other baking recipes that
i've done
so let's go with that flour
okay nice beautiful two teaspoons of
baking powder one teaspoon of salt pour
skip the step of mixing it so i assume
we still have to mix it all right i'll
do that first
[Applause]
next step pour the dough into one and a
half cup of round cake
[Music]
is that saying pour a cup and a half of
the batter
into the round
cake pan the next step is place all the
dough in the other baking pan so it must
mean that one okay i'll do a cup and a
half in the round pan and the rest in
the baking sheet i'm going with my heart
yeah
making sure it's even it doesn't say
that but i assume i assume that this is
needed i'm gonna put that to the side
and then i'm gonna i guess put the rest
in here you feel good about that
i'm just kidding i'm just kidding
i don't know how i feel about it anymore
it's a pretty batter thank you
the next step is bake for 10 to 12
minutes until the teeth are clean i
think we're gonna bake it
and then we'll test it with a fork and
if it comes clean off the fork teeth
it's ready not getting any i'm not intel
confirmation but i feel like you're you
should go with your heart your your
heart seems strong okay are you able to
kind of piece together what you're
making right now well right now it kind
of seems like we're gonna like bake it
and i'll roll it or something
because it makes me think
it's so thin and so if i'm making a like
some sort of log cake i could roll it
but like this really confuses me bake
for 10 to 12 minutes until the teeth are
clean let's go
i'm just gonna put on the lower rack i
always do that
okay i guess they'll go on both
i'll do 10 minutes now and i'll just
check on it later i will just wait here
until the teeth are clean
all right let's open this up
it's the 10 minute mark right now
teeth are clean
let's go back to the kitchen okay we
have our cakes they look fine i'm not
even sure if this is what it's supposed
to look like so the next step is to
spray sugar with a towel i'm thinking
about synonyms for spray
dust with sugar spray sugar with a towel
so i guess i'm gonna put sugar on the
towel i don't know if that's right but
you know what life is about learning
from your failures so we're gonna do
that let's use the whole towel i'm so
confused
this feels very wrong this feels like
i'm purposely making a mess my mom's
gonna come in and yell at me i'm
assuming this will just help it not
stick
then again
i don't know what i'm doing i was
spreading it but then katie furrowed her
eyebrows so i changed my mind
the air is sweet now have you done
anything like this before no
okay so next is turn the dough into a
curved crust on a towel and lift the
towel to wrap the cake into a stick
so it must be this one if it's if it's
rolling it into a log
okay i'm going to remove the skin
turn the dough into a curved crust on a
towel i guess we're just gonna roll it i
have no idea what i'm making
i've never seen this technique but i
think i have a beautifully curved crust
now so let's move on to the next step
which is freeze the cake for 15 minutes
okay i'm gonna put this here and uh
freeze it for 15 minutes we have our
cake out of the freezer
the next step is remove the log and
spread a three-quarter glass jar in a
bowl on top of the cake you know what
this feels like this feels like when
you're on your phone and you do autofill
and it's just words and then none of it
makes sense that's how it feels
there's one glass jar so it must be this
in a bowl on top of the cake i have a
bowl and i'm gonna put three quarter
cups of strawberry preserves you know
maybe there are some words that you
don't need you know like maybe there are
words in there that are just words so
maybe i don't need this bowl
the next step says to roll the cake so
that means i can
presume that i'm unrolling it now oh
okay so three quarter cups on top of
this and then roll it back up i haven't
had to use my brain this much the entire
panorama
pandemic spread on top of cake roll the
cake cover it with a plastic bag and let
it freeze 10 minutes
cover it with plastic wrap freeze for 10
minutes 10 hours
now i need my plastic bag
wrap it completely i assume i think
that's good okay freeze 10 minutes brb
again that was more straightforward than
the earlier instructions so i'm happy i
have my cake out from the freezer and
the next step is to assemble a plastic
cover for a bowl so in my head i'm just
thinking i need to prepare some saran
wrap to put on the bowl
so that's what i'll do i feel like i'm
doing something pretty useless right now
it's probably wrong now cut the jelly
ankle into inch inch slices in a bowl to
cover bottom inside
cut jelly ankle cut jelly ankle
jelly ankle this looks kind of like
a leg though not an ankle okay so maybe
it's this
let me okay inch inch slices in a bowl
oh
oh
okay okay
so the uh this plastic cover for the
bowl i think actually we're gonna
push it in
and line the bowl i'm gonna go with the
double layer just to be safe
so i think i'm gonna need to take this
cake and slice it into inch thick slices
and then line the bowl
what i think
i don't think i've ever made anything
like this so the process is very new for
me
put it in the center
oh that's cute okay next step do the
filling
add one tablespoon of gelatin with a
quarter cup of cold water bake for five
minutes we wouldn't bake the
my my
heat heat dissolve dissolve the gelatin
in the water
i think it'll just i'm gonna let it
bloom for five minutes i'm calling the
shots
gelatin i need a quarter cup of water
tablespoon of gelatin i'm gonna read the
next step make 16 ounces of cottage
cheese
one cup of powdered sugar
one tablespoon vanilla extract fell into
crater whisk until fluffy and fluffy let
me just absorb that for a second
16 ounces of cottage cheese i feel like
this is a dessert that should have cream
cheese not cottage cheese there's cream
cheese on the table
bowl
i'm grabbing the bowl because the
directions said fell into crater and
this is the only thing that resembles a
crater so i think that it would be to
put everything in a bowl so i'll need
two of these now uh one cup of powdered
sugar and then one tablespoon vanilla
extract whisk until fluffy and fluffy
i'm assuming light and fluffy
awesome
okay next step gently mix two heavy cans
and whisk until tops are noticeable
heavy cans
heavy
whipping cream
cans evaporated milk condensed milk okay
i think i'm gonna gently mix two cups of
heavy whipping cream and whisk until
their
tops are noticeable whisk until peaks
form i'm gonna go with that two cups
should i mix it while i pour it
nah
can't be bothered
can't follow all the rules while you
cook it's no fun that way
this is a lot of filling
you know i think that's good i don't
even really know if i've needed peaks
for frosting add gelatin and stir to mix
let's get our gelatin
i think maybe bake was heat
and so maybe it was microwave for five
minutes that's really long i feel like
it would explode and make a mess okay
they're laughing at me so definitely not
i think i'm just gonna heat it until it
dissolves again and becomes liquid and
then i'll mix it in there okay brb so i
have my gelatin it's in liquid form now
so i'm just gonna dump that in this kind
of feels like i'm making a no-bake
cheesecake all right next one follow the
strawberry in i would say that means
follow with strawberry in here
or in there if the recipe is not
referencing this i i assume that it
would mean this one here are some
strawberries
dice slice no direction you know what
i'm just gonna dice it and throw it in
there i don't know how much how many
strawberries to put in but i'm gonna do
it until it's filled with strawberries
because i feel like desserts don't give
enough strawberries in the desserts fill
the top of the cake with the cheesecake
filling then place the round loaf on top
so now i just learned what that round
loaf is for okay so that's the bottom of
the cake i think it means to throw the
sliced strawberries in the filling
though i don't want to do that can i
reject that you can do whatever you
would like hell yeah
okay
i brought this back
i am going to put a layer of the
cheesecake filling found out it's
cheesecake filling so i'm going to do
like one layer of cheesecake filling and
then i'm going to line it with
strawberries and then do another layer
of frosting and then another layer of
strawberries i think that'll be good i
think right now i got a whiff of cake
filling and strawberries together so it
tells me what it could possibly taste
like i think i'm improving the recipe
this is now strawberry kinking that's
good let's go in with the second layer
of cheesecake filling all right okay
more strawberries we're getting there
we're getting there i'm gonna go in with
the rest of the cheesecake filling i
almost feel like you were too good at
this jasmine maybe i should have made
these harder did i do it right i don't
know i'm telling you yes
but you've been doing a nice job
is that why you're so quiet yes that's
why i don't want to give you any more
help
i feel like when i put the round cake on
top
the open spaces like right here are not
going to look very nice and katie has
high standards so
i am going to cut a few more slices i
think here is good i think it looks
great i think i did great i'm excited
about eating it
this cake is beautiful i'm gonna do it
this side
so now we keep it in the refrigerator
for an hour i'm packing it in right now
they're laughing again i never know what
that means let's just put this in the
fridge for an hour we'll get to the next
step when we get to it
so the dessert is in the fridge and we
have a few more steps cook in a small
saucepan and add three
slash cup sugar to two slash cup water
yeah i'll do a third cup of sugar to
half a cup of water
i think we're making caramel i think the
next step
beat together the corn and two
tablespoons of cold water and then beat
in boiling sugar syrup corn oh
corn starch how much how much
how much
it doesn't say
well if i put too much it'll be
too thick and if i don't put enough it
can be too runny i'll put two
tablespoons um you know what let's start
with less half tablespoon to
a teaspoon and a half so
1.5 i needed two oh times four one point
five times four
to sixty six six teaspoons is
two tablespoons are you panicking right
now
can you hear it in my voice i feel like
you're nervous again i'm all it's very
nerve-wracking this seems like a pretty
good color actually i put two full
tablespoons
wait wait wait wait wait wait wait
[Music]
i did the math completely wrong i just
did a one-to-one ratio
that's how i feel right now
i can't do the math i give up let's just
do one beat together the corn and two
tablespoons of cold water it's a lot of
pressure you're doing great i'm proud of
you okay now i prepare the food
and remove it from the heat and leave it
for a while
that's so casual just chill for all i
know this is a whole separate dish the
cake is never referenced again in the
recipe so strawberry king king is
missing quite a lot
okay i got the cake back even though the
recipe dropped the cake completely i
didn't even do anything with put the
glass in a pot i just have no idea the
last step is to serve place a plate on a
plate and slide carefully remove the
bowl and the remaining air thighs
okay so i think i'm just gonna
unwrap this
place the plate on the bowl
on top of the bowl place the plate on
top of the bowl
and
turn not slide
okay
suspense
okay
oh baby okay we got it and the remaining
air thighs the remaining
plastic wrap
okay and
just like it never referenced the cake
again it it also doesn't reference the
the syrup again so then i will i don't
know anymore so i'm just gonna pour this
on top i'm sorry if it's wrong i'm sorry
if i messed up your favorite dessert
that's not cute okay this is good now
it's glazed it's so shiny yeah i'm not
sure if it's supposed to look like this
but i did the best that i can and
right now that's all i can say are you
done
uh i think i need to serve it
plate plate and slide strawberry king
king
there you go ah okay can i leave
oh wow
okay
do you want to know what this actual
dessert is called yes what a strawberry
king king story hanging is
strawberry charlotte royale i think
strawberry king king actually sounds
better this is a lot better
look at these holes look at the
difference well this is really beautiful
um i did my best and from what i can see
it's not incredibly far off so i i think
i did a pretty good job i think you did
so good
thanks katie i can't believe how well
you did
i was actually like it's not hard enough
for mine i think all the elements are
there it's the right shape although
obviously we got some exposed filling
the original one is a lot more precise
in technique it just looks a little more
refined than mine they look similar but
let's see how they taste you ready for
this oh i'm scared
i think it looks pretty good
wow actually it looks the same yeah
i'm gonna try mine first and then i'll
try the original afterwards cheers
mmm
it's good tastes like a strawberry
shortcake which i love so now i'll try
the original one
this tastes like it's from a store
strawberry king king give it a try and
let us know in the comments below if you
want us to do this again bye
oh yes
[Music]
you